[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde à qui profite l'héritage un
sujet Combien d'actualités l'héritage
est une transmission de bien matériel et
de liens symbolique c'est une opération
qui relève du passé révélant secret de
famille et histoire enfouie concerne à
la fois le présent avec une succession à
répartir en fonction des droits plus ou
moins définis et qui va impacter des
destins individuels et l'avenir des
générations mais cela concerne également
l'évolution des sociétés si l'héritage
s'inscrit dans la lignée naturelle des
hommes et des femmes c'est aussi une
préoccupation majeure pour les États
pour les entreprises parce qu'il est
question d'affaires de succession l'État
doit à la fois fixer le montant des
impôts sur les successions une recette
nette pour l'État se montrer impartial
face aux appétits conflictuelles privées
et trouver un juste milieu de
répartition pour éviter la transmission
des inégalités d'un point de vue
psychologique l'héritage révèle toute la
palette humaine des sentiments l'amour
la haine l'envie la jalousie la cupidité
c'est pourquoi l'héritage figure en
bonne place dans la littérature le
cinéma lézard il défrait l'acronique des
faits divers et passionnent les foules
nous allons engager le débat pour en
savoir plus avec Claire Fournier vous
êtes journaliste à LCI Boualem sans
salles vous êtes écrivains Patrick Abran
vous êtes psychanalyste et écrivain
Christian Saint-Étienne vous êtes
économiste et professeur émérite au CNAM
[Musique]
alors une première question personnelle
nous avons toutes et tous une histoire
de famille et nous nous inscrivons tous
dans une lignée des générations mais
peuvent-t-on dire que nous appartenons
tous à une société d'héritier par
exemple Claire Fournier vous êtes
héritier de quoi
je suis
héritière de rien financièrement puisque
mes parents lorsqu'ils auront atteint
l'âge d'entrer dans l'autre monde auront
déjà dépensé une grande partie de leur
épargne pour bien financer leur vieux
jours ou pour
avoir épargné pour pour leurs
petits-enfants leurs enfants donc
moi-même je mériterais de rien et c'est
tant mieux parce que
vous en transmis comme
héritage
évidemment des valeurs
voilà des valeurs qui effectivement
rentrent dans mon capital culturel et je
lancerai éternellement reconnaissant
c'est pour ça que si je ne suis pas
héritière de Somme trébuchantes et bien
ça ne me dérange pas et d'ailleurs c'est
très bien comme cela puisque c'est une
facteur d'inégalité comme on va en
reparler dans le détail moi-même sans
sale vous vous êtes l'héritier de quoi
vous n'êtes pas venu à la littérature
par hasard non
rien n'arrive par hasard dans la vie
tout est quelque part très déterminée
organisé
d'abord je suis l'héritier de de mes
parents je tiens à mon nom
je sais pas pourquoi mon nom me plaît
bien c'est une
et sans sale ça vient d'où et ça dit
très mystérieux parce que il ne
se rallie aucune culture il n'est pas
dans la tradition française il n'y a pas
dans la traditions arabes on sait pas
d'où vient ce nom
donc c'est une curiosité en Algérie
vraiment c'est une curiosité à chaque
fois que je prononce mon nom quoi d'où
ça vient qui êtes-vous d'où venez-vous
alors voilà c'est je suis un peu inconnu
et en plus alors
pareil pour mon prénom montrez-nous
n'existe qu'en Algérie c'est pas un
prénom arabe c'est un prénom berbère et
qui veut dire c'est très là aussi c'est
gratifiant bon à l'homme ça a deux sens
celui qui porte le drapeau à l'âme c'est
le rapport en arabe mon berbère aussi
celui qui porte le drapeau et bout rimes
avec un i c'est celui qui détient la
science vous êtes bien alors
c'est quoi le drapeau de Patrick avrane
mon drapeau je pensais effectivement en
entendant ce que vous disiez moi je
pourrais dire je suis héritier de deux
grands-mères il y en a une qui parlait
bretons et l'autre qui parlait yiddish
alors ça fait un drôle de drapeau ça
donne peut-être un psychanalyste ça
donne un psychanalyse qui a un prénom
très breton et un nom qui vient bien sûr
avrane et Abraham à la différence près
il y a quelque chose de très curieux
quand ce nom a été francisé il y a une
seule famille pour lequel ça a été écrit
comme ça les avranes nous sommes très
peu nombreux nous sommes une famille
c'est celle qui est issue de mes
grands-parents et puis ça fait partie de
mon héritage et puis dans les héritages
il y a ce que l'on reçoit comme bien
disposition et puis à ce qu'on reçoit
comme bien matériel conséquent et puis
il est aussi toutes ces petites choses
dans mon bureau j'aime par exemple
quelque chose un espèce un petit bronze
qui vient de mon grand-père maternel qui
avait été donné à part un de ses amis
avec la Bretagne ou le reste c'est la
Bretagne et un de ses amis avec qui il
avait fait Verdun lui a donné ce petit
bronze il se trouve que au moment de son
décès j'ai eu envie de le récupérer et
ce petit bronze il m'accompagne il est
là dans mon bureau par exemple et vous
Christian Saint-Étienne c'est quoi le
drapeau de Christian
mes parents étaient instituteur de
l'école laïque et à ces militants de ça
donc je pense que c'est un élément
d'héritage absolument majeur je pense
qu'ils m'ont transmis aussi
la un désir d'excellence voilà sinon je
suis comme claire il y a eu enfin mes
parents sont décédés il y a eu aucun
héritage financier mais
je pense que c'est cette cette volonté
d'excellence mais pourquoi on a honte
d'avoir un héritage financier ah moi
j'aurais été très content de recevoir
des millions soyons clairs
je signale simplement puisque vous posez
la question qu'il n'y avait pas de
millions voir donc Christiane n'est pas
né avec des milieux alors on va rentrer
dans le vif du sujet l'histoire de
l'héritage dans un pays obéit à des
considérations socio-économiques
politiques spirituel et religieuse à
votre avis Claire Fournier
c'est quoi le plus important finalement
dans l'héritage le l'économie le
culturel le spirituel et comment vous
imbriquez tout ça parce que ça n'est pas
qu'une histoire d'argent on va rentrer
on va en parler dans le détail toutes
les questions difficiles en premier lieu
alors écoutez l'héritage bien évidemment
que c'est avant tout un héritage
culturel c'est qui on est lorsqu'on
voilà et dans quelle famille on est ça
c'est fondamental évidemment ensuite
pour déterminer comme on va avancer dans
la vie après qu'il y ait de l'argent ou
pas ça ne fait pas de vous une meilleure
ou une plus mauvaise personne mais bien
évidemment que ce n'est pas l'héritage
financier qui prime néanmoins
aujourd'hui il y a des choses qui font
que cet héritage qu'on le veuille ou non
il prend une part de plus en plus
importante aujourd'hui par exemple c'est
beaucoup plus difficile de commencer
dans la vie de monter sa boîte de faire
un emprunt immobilier si on n'a pas un
apport familial donc ça rentre en ligne
de compte quand même même si bien
évidemment ça n'est plus ça n'est pas le
plus important et l'héritage le plus
important pour un enfant en tout cas moi
qui est de jeunes enfants c'est à la
fois l'héritage culturel familial et
puis ce qu'il apprend avant tout à
l'école alors Patrick Abraham Claire
Fournier vienne dire que le l'argent est
important mais ne fait pas tout dans
l'héritage mais comment tout ça se
mélange en quelque sorte pour fabriquer
un héritier un non héritier est-ce qu'on
reconnaît comme ça quelqu'un qui est un
héritier je sais pas si on reconnaît
quelqu'un qui est un héritier
mais on oublie que nous sommes soumis
aux règles de la société dans laquelle
nous vivons c'est-à-dire que nous ne
sommes pas
héritiers aujourd'hui comme nous
l'aurions été à l'ancien régime et comme
nous le saurions dans un autre pays
notamment le Saxon c'est-à-dire qu'il y
a pas il y a pas un héritage dans lequel
chacun rentre de la même façon il rentre
dans l'héritage en fonction de là où il
est de l'époque je voudrais vous faire
préciser cette chose là dans une même
famille pays les conditions sociales
sont à peu près les mêmes disons pour
les enfants comment se fait-il que
l'héritage soit
divertiments fécondées
a priori dans une famille en France tous
les enfants sont au même niveau
ce qui crée au départ on oublie en même
temps que quand on hérite on hérite du
parent que l'on a connu les frères et
soeurs n'ont pas le même parent ils sont
le même parents bien évidemment
physiologiquement simplement ce ne sont
pas les mêmes ils sont à des âges
différents les parents étaient pas là
même donc nécessairement il y a quand on
est riche chacun hérite de quelque chose
qui n'est pas exactement la même chose
que l'autre même si au niveau matériel
c'est
identique et c'est à partir de là que
les choses vont être différentes et
chacun pourra pourra par exemple
détester
la maison dont il hérite parce que ça
lui plaît pas du tout cette maison de
famille alors que l'autre vaudra la
garder parce que c'est l'endroit où il
était heureux et parfois ça crée des
conflits alors sur la question
économique Christian Saint-Étienne
l'héritage c'est bien souvent une
transmission qui fait suite à une
succession etc chaque pays a sa propre
légis pour ce qui est de la France qui
est en droit d'hériter et est-ce qu'on
peut déshériter
alors il y a des par réservateurs donc
qui protège les enfants en France alors
que ce n'est pas le cas dans d'autres
pays mais je voudrais préciser sur le
plan économique que 90% des gens
reçoivent un héritage extrêmement limité
sur le plan financier puisqu'il y a une
concentration des fortunes considérables
et donc ça veut dire tout de même que
pour moi
l'héritage financier
dans l'héritage global qu'on reçoit
c'est un peu comme l'iceberg c'est à
dire que la partie financière c'est la
partie émergée c'est ce qu'on voit et je
pense que la partie immergée qui est la
plus importante c'est à dire celle qui
nous a appris les principaux réflexes
qu'on a dans la vie qui nous a appris la
part du travail et la part de la chance
et la façon dont on va se relier aux
autres c'est c'est très important alors
donc la partie émergée c'est à dire l'A
financier ça va sur certainement changer
la trajectoire des personnes qui
reçoivent une fortune
considérable si vous êtes l'héritier de
la famille Fiat et que vous vous
retrouvez à la tête d'une holding qui
manipule les milliards ça change
forcément votre destinée mais pour 90%
des gens l'argent qu'il reçoive n'est
pas n'est pas de nature à changer leur
destinée au clair fourni est-ce que vous
pourriez compléter en disant est-ce
qu'on peut déshériter en France ou pas
alors déjà je souhaiterais compléter ce
que disait Christian Saint-Étienne sur
effectivement le peu de gens qui
héritent de sommes conséquentes en
France il faut savoir d'abord qu'une
personne sur deux mérite pas et
qu'ensuite l'héritage moyen il est
autour de 130
et que l'héritage moyen c'est 130 000
euros voilà donc ça remet un petit peu
les bases de effectivement ce qui fait
que chaque personne tu n'es pas
hérite en moyenne ça qui veut pas dire
pour l'ensemble cette année il y en a
qui sont à zéro sont des gens vont avoir
quelques milliers d'euros et puis il y a
des questions je vous ai posé
voilà on peut pas déshériter un enfant
complètement en vertu de la réserve
héréditaire qui qui en effet et cette
cette loi héritée du Code civil de
Napoléon qui n'a pas changé jusqu'à
aujourd'hui et qui stipule que si vous
avez un enfant il a droit à 50% de votre
votre héritage si vous en avez deux et
il a droit aux deux tiers et ça bouge
pas et si vous en avez trois ils ont
plus ils ont droit aux trois quarts donc
vous ne pouvez pas déshériter un enfant
vous pouvez dans une certaine mesure
avantagée l'un de vos enfants avec oui
avec 25% qui s'appelle la quotité
disponible vous pouvez décider que c'est
un peu nos enfants qui en bénéficient
mais contrairement aux pays anglo-saxon
en effet vous pouvez totalement
déshériter vos enfants comme vous comme
bon vous le semble en France ce n'est
pas possible
alors avec vous pour aller me sens seule
je vais poser la question en terme
anthropologique vous savez que chaque
société a son système d'héritage et que
quelque part ça montre le niveau de
démocratie de civilisation est-ce que
dans les pays arabes les femmes et les
hommes
héritent de la même manière alors petite
rectification dans le monde musulmans
parce qu'il y a des Arabes oui vous avez
raison dans le monde musulman
dans le monde musulman la question est
hyper simple elle est déjà codifiée dans
le courant vous n'avez rien à décider ni
à déshérité voilà
un calcul très précis
c'est-à-dire et ben
vous le garçon vous avez hérité si vous
avez une sœur elle a rien eu
dont rien non il y a un petit quelque
chose
hérite d'après la loi coranique
évidemment les pauses et les enfants
mais les oncles les cousins les la tribu
c'est comme dans la royauté alors c'est
comme dans la royauté donc la procédure
est extrêmement longue parce que pour
retrouver les héritiers dans dans il
faut chercher des années des années
rendez-vous compte par exemple en
Algérie quelqu'un qui hérite d'une
grosse fortune et pour retrouver la
tribu il faut peut-être 20 ans 30 ans
ils sont en attendant c'est l'État qui
non le temps ne prend rien du tout ne
prend rien non d'automne n'est pas et
qui
c'est la tribu voilà et donc vigueur
actuellement dans tous les pays arabes
aux musulmans absolument ce sont sur la
ligne corale certains pays ont pris des
libertés avec la loi coranique mais dans
l'ensemble c'est tout à fait respecter
c'est un donc on hérite
je dirais on
hérite à la fin de sa vie quoi
tellement ça prend de temps pour
retrouver les héritiers
est-ce qu'ils sont vivants est-ce qu'ils
sont pas vivants est-ce que eux-mêmes
ont des enfants parce que leurs enfants
irritent c'est très compliqué alors une
fortune comme la fortune de Fiat dans un
système musulman est divisé en 1000
milliards de parties qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez Patrick Abran un commentaire
là-dessus c'était absolument étonnant
c'est à dire que ça n'a rien à voir avec
la façon dont l'héritage fonctionne en
France jusqu'à ce moment-là les
héritiers ce qu'on appelle les héritiers
de premier rang qui en général sont les
enfants exclut tous les autres il n'y a
on hérite de son oncle de sa tante que
s'il n'y a pas d'enfant
et bien évidemment ça ça met en place
quelque chose de radicalement différent
quand on lien de parenté c'est à dire
qu'en France on considère à ce moment-là
ça se voit que la famille c'est de la
famille ce qu'on appelle la famille
nucléaire d'abord
dans les pays musulmans c'est étendu à
tout le monde et effectivement il y a
aussi autre chose c'est que je vois que
c'est illimité dans le temps alors que
pour autant que je sache en France il y
a des limites qui sont très strictes
au-delà d'un certain temps toute façon
il faut payer les droits de succession
et puis et puis si on trouve pas
d'héritiers c'est l'État qui empoche
alors pardon
dans le monde musulman on l'a quand même
trouvé des parades c'est la donation
donc on précède
voilà on répartit ça sur son patrimoine
entre ses enfants cette inégalité selon
ses préférences
également en France
on va passer le pays des inégalités
entre les Belges des pays aux
entreprises à votre avis Claire Fournier
au niveau des entreprises la
transmission familiale de l'héritage
peut porter atteinte au management
est-ce que les descendants en général ne
disposent pas des qualités de leur
géniteur est-ce que vous aimeriez
favorable à ce que l'État interviennent
dans la conduite de l'entreprise au
niveau de la succession pour décider que
ça ne soit pas automatique non je ne
suis pas favorable à ce que l'État
interviennent
pas non en revanche je ne suis pas une
fanatique du capitalisme familial de la
transmission familiale d'une entreprise
à tout craint parce qu'en effet on
trouve parfois d'excellents managers on
trouve même souvent d'excellents
managers en dehors de la famille et il y
a alors ça ce sont des chercheurs
américains qui l'ont démontré par
exemple il y a aussi une forme de
déperdition pense qu'une entreprise
alors c'est pas dans 100% des cas mais
il peut y avoir une forme de déperdition
quand il y a transmission d'entreprise
de génération en génération c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'effet Budden Brock et
qui veut que la deuxième génération par
exemple fait 30 % moins bien que la
première et que il y a des risques de
fermeture de l'entreprise familiale et
c'est encore pire pour la troisième
génération donc c'est pas dans les gènes
si vous voulez être être un bon
entrepreneurs
c'est intéressant c'est que en France on
a une transmission familiale
d'entreprise qui offre de nombreux
exemples où ça très très bien marché par
exemple vous vous prenez les entreprises
les championnes françaises du CAC 40 par
exemple pour beaucoup ce sont des
entreprises familiales
je ne suis pas une fanatique du
capitalisme familial je ne suis pas bien
sûr qu'une entreprise qui soit dans les
mains d'une famille par exemple traite
mieux ses salariés ou soit mieux
performantes comme on semble avoir cette
sorte de fantasme là
même question mais posée autrement si on
prend les champions du CAC 40 ça
représente beaucoup d'argent
s'apaise dans l'économie du pays
c'est-à-dire que la stabilité du d'un
pays dépend de est-ce qu'on peut laisser
dans ce cas là une transmission dont
j'allais dire biologique automatique
[Musique]
biologique automatique non mais qui peut
interne néanmoins il faut quand même
regarder qu'au niveau mondial
c'est-à-dire si on prend ne serait-ce
que les 30 pays les plus développés
la transmission familiale est la règle
c'est à dire que si même si vous prenez
aux États-Unis ou dans d'autres pays les
entreprises familiales sont majoritaires
dans ce que en France on appellerait les
TPE PME et gros quand vous arrivez à des
très très grosses entreprises
internationales côté généralement pour
que ces entreprises se développent la
part du capital familial a baissé et
c'est par le jeu des droits de vote
qu'on peut maintenir ou non le contrôle
de l'entreprise alors vous évoquez la
question qui est complexe de qu'est-ce
qui se passe si les héritiers sont pas
bons bon on a par exemple si on veut pas
nommer les gens
Lagardère le fils Lagardère à bousillé
l'héritage de son père qui avait
construit un grand groupe international
dans l'aéronautique et qui avait
développé un groupe dans les médias
considérables à contrario si vous prenez
la famille Bouygues la l'héritage du
fondateur a été développé par ses
héritiers par exemple pour les familles
Pinot Arnaud et chez Pino Arnaud est en
cours etc alors qu'est-ce qui se passe
dans ce dans certaines de ces familles
lorsque les héritiers
ne se sentent pas capables de gérer des
entreprises multinationales de grande
ampleur généralement on fait appel à un
manager extérieur c'est là où ce qui est
très important c'est de distinguer
l'actionnariat le management donc ça
suppose que dans ces familles il est
suffisamment d'humilité pour aller
chercher des managers à l'extérieur
quand on se rend compte qu'on n'est pas
capable de les gérer mais je franchirai
une étape supplémentaire il y a une
institution qui manque en France parce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure que au
fond pourquoi pas ce serait ça serait
allé à l'état de décider par exemple
dans ce cas-là on tombe dans une
économie totalement administrée premier
élément deuxième élément l'état n'existe
pas c'est à dire que sont des personnes
physiques qui vont prendre les décisions
elles peuvent être achetées elles
peuvent avoir des intérêts direct ou
indirect de prendre une décision au lot
donc je préfère et je pense que c'est
très important de le dire pour les
spectateurs c'est qu'il existe une
institution très intelligente en
Allemagne et en Italie et dans d'autres
pays qui s'appelle la fondation et je
pense que ce qui serait en France très
cher
de créer ce que j'appelle les fondations
de production donc on pourra parler tout
à l'heure on va parler tout à l'heure
[Musique]
passons à la littérature Patrick avrane
l'héritage est un matériau littéraire
par excellence vous en faites usage
pourquoi
parce que l'héritage c'est quelque chose
qui nous a été transmis et la
littérature est là aussi pour nous
transmettre et quand on voit ce que
raconte la fontaine le laboureur et ses
enfants et bien on vient exactement dans
parler c'est à dire que qu'est-ce qu'il
qu'est-ce qui se transmet ou qu'est-ce
qui se transmet pas il y a parfois un
fondateur de l'entreprise les
entreprises dont vous parlez la garde
L'Oréal il y a eu un fondateur
les successeurs les enfants les
héritiers n'ont pas nécessairement le
même désir que le fondateur
quand il y a du désir qui s'est transmis
quand les enfants du laboureur ont envie
eux-mêmes de labourer alors à ce
moment-là et bien on pourrait dire la
ferme prospère si non pas même désir
c'est parce que il faut autre chose
parce que c'est pas leur histoire
effectivement faut trouver une autre
solution et je dirais ça fait parfois
partie de ce que les analystes entendent
quand des héritiers ils leur tendent
quelque chose dont ils font ils ne
savent pas quoi en faire ça les encombre
et là il y a effectivement poser une
question précise vous qui êtes
psychanalyste dans les familles quand le
père est médecin chef d'entreprise
avocat ou laboureur
les enfants qui sont dans la filiation
et qui font le même métier vous
considérez que ce sont des héritiers
directs et les autres sont des héritiers
indirectes comment vous et qu'est-ce qui
fait que les arbres reprennent ce
flambeau et que d'autres ont besoin
d'aller ailleurs je dirais pas ça de
tout le monde quand un médecin on ne rit
pas de son cabinet bon priorité de sa
clientèle éventuellement c'est pas la
même chose quand on quand on hérite
d'une entreprise effectivement
celui qui est le fils du médecin il a
une certaine connaissance une habitude
peut-être que ça lui donne le désir de
faire le même métier mais parfois très
souvent ça lui donne plutôt le désir de
fuir celui qui
hérite d'une entreprise il est obligé de
il ne peut pas fuir il doit faire avec
oui mais laissons ou pas laissons le
matériel de côté mais le maquette qui
fait que un médecin
et des enfants qui veulent être médecins
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il se lignage
là signifie quelque chose je pense que
bien évidemment il y a un lignage de
transmission
de façon de faire on sait très bien aux
enfants vous avez sous et si vous en
avez est-ce que vous avez souhaité qu'il
soit par exemple psychanalyse ou
écrivain certainement pas non
mes enfants ont suivi ont suivi le
chemin de leur mère c'est-à-dire que ce
sont ce sont des scientifiques pures
souches et ils ont fait les plus grandes
écoles qu'il y a et sont strictement
scientifiques
vous avez l'air heureux de ça voilà
problème vous êtes un immense écrivain
beaucoup de romans
c'est quoi la part de l'héritage dans
tous vos romans est-ce que c'est ça qui
je crois que l'héritage avant tout
au-delà de la question passez mondiale
etc c'est une énigme de la vie
on mérite pas que de ses parents on
hérite de ces ondes de sa grand-mère de
du milieu dans lequel on vit de un
espace beaucoup plus large c'est très
complexe et c'est très mouvant au fil du
temps tout à l'heure vous parlez des
différentes étapes de la vie on est
préparé à
mais entrer dans ce qui va venir dans le
monde qui arrive on est préparé par
par des leçons familiales par l'école
par la République par oui mais dans ce
que vous écrivez dans ce que vous
écrivez chacun face à cela au fur et à
mesure qu'il avance en âge et en raison
c'est à lui de se déterminer
il peut vouloir
[Musique]
complètement on est bien d'accord mais
dans vos romans quelle est la part de
l'héritage c'est-à-dire est-ce que ça
des scènes inconscientes qui reviennent
à travers votre la lecture de vos
on arrive à savoir qui est le l'intime
de Boualem Sansal l'intime de bonhomme
en salle sur cette question là je crois
que c'est Albert Camus
et ma mère étaient des amis intimes
donc moi j'ai bien connu cette famille
je savais pas ce que j'étais gamin
Albert Camus pour moi c'était c'était
surtout en footballeur
cet âge là 400 j'ai eu la même relation
j'ai eu la même position avec Jacques
Derrida on parlait de football
voilà alors qu'il est connu ailleurs
parce que voilà dans le quartier nous
admirions Albert Camus parce que c'était
un footballeur et voilà il faisait
partie de l'équipe du quartier et puis
avec le temps on la découverte j'ai
découvert ce qu'est que écrivain voulait
dire
mais petit à petit des fois on devient
très lentement lorsque soi-même on
découvre que entendre et parler dans la
vie importante
quoi dire et quoi entendre et c'est la
leçon de la vie donc c'est venu tout
doucement tout doucement
ensuite on découvre un moment donné on
l'attrape le bout de la ficelle et on
tire et on est ensuite est-ce que vous
voulez dire
est-ce que vous voulez dire qu'il y
aurait pas eu moi-même sans sale s'il y
avait pas eu Camus s'il y avait pas eu
catabiaci s'il y avait pas eu Mouloud
Feraoun est-ce que finalement vous êtes
le produit d'un lignage intellectuel et
littéraire parce que je me suis trouvé
dans ce contexte là c'est un hasard qui
fait que nous étions voisins avec les
Camus et ainsi de suite que j'ai connu
ensuite
etc
peut-être aussi il faut le dire c'est le
talent personnel parce que j'ai beaucoup
d'amis qui ont connu Camus qui ont connu
caterbiacine qui est pourtant ne sont
pas écrivains mais ça c'est les hasards
de la vie moi je suis comme vos enfants
j'étais scientifique
lorsque l'indépendance est arrivé moi je
voulais faire philo des choses comme ça
quoi et puis le gouvernement algérien
venait s'installer
la religion par cœur et on applique on
n'a pas on n'a pas à discuté de la vie
du sens de la vie c'est déjà près de
déterminer donc c'est ce que je voulais
faire l'indépendance arrivée moi j'étais
vous avez été aux Françaises philosophe
pour moi c'était c'était le summum de la
interdit ces choses j'ai entrepôt j'ai
philosophique c'est ta bannière il faut
faire des études scientifique médecin
ingénieurs architecte c'est comme ça que
je me suis trouvé dans les filières
scientifiques donc je fais des
ingénieurs et puis
ensuite j'ai découvert que vous voulez
dire qu'il y a pas de déterminisme
on peut avoir c'est complet on peut pas
répondre à la question il y a une part
de déterminer
une part de la volonté générale par
exemple le gouvernement avait décidé que
donc moi je suis ration il fallait tous
faire des études ingénieur après on a
dit voilà
d'économie parce que je crois qu'on ne
peut la science pure et dure ne permet
pas de comprendre la société en revanche
la sociologie est une grille de lecture
fantastique
parce que c'est des structures sociales
à la base de Colombie et des structures
philosophiques donc c'est important donc
j'ai découvert que c'est pas c'est il
faut aller plus loin c'est la
littérature permet de rentrer dans un
univers symbolique qui est peut-être
plus intéressant on va essayer de
trouver un point explicatif Patrick
de notre famille j'ai parlé de mes
enfants bien sûr ils ont fait des études
scientifiques néanmoins ils savent elles
savent c'est de ce que c'est que
l'inconscient et de ces études
scientifiques elles sont travaillées
dans ce qu'on appelle des grands
cabinets de conseil
c'est-à-dire que il y a les deux à la
fois et je pense qu'effectivement c'est
aussi ça c'est une transmission qui est
ce que j'aurais pu lorsque j'ai pu leur
transmettre ce que c'est qu'un lapsus
qu'un acte manqué ce que forcément leur
petit copain quand elles étaient en
prépa ne savaient pas
alors moi je voudrais vous poser une
question claire Fournier on ne peut pas
évoquer les querelles d'héritage sans
parler de ce qui fait
comment dire j'allais dire la fureur de
vivre enfin ce qui mobilise l'opinion
publique avec beaucoup d'affaires alors
il y a l'affaire à l'idée qu'on a eu
chez nous mais il y a beaucoup de
divorce de gens fortunés
quelles leçons vous tirer de ce
déballage médiatique alors je pense que
ça part ça n'est pas économique mais
pourquoi ça passionne des fois ça
passionne les foules et ça parle
énormément de français parce que ma
conviction intime c'est qu'il n'y a
aucune famille où l'héritage se passe
bien enfin il y en a ou d'apparence ça
peut de se passer de manière civile etc
mais comme on le disait tout à l'heure
hérité de ses parents c'est ce placer
dans une lignée c'est
redécouvrir les relations qu'on avait
avec ses parents avec ses frères et
sœurs bon alors peut-être viser parce
que dans ma famille ça c'est
horriblement mal passé mais j'entends
peu de d'histoire d'héritage qui qui se
passe bien et quelque part on disait
tout à l'heure il y a peut-être pas de
déterminisme etc mais il y a la notion
que lorsqu'on hérite on est redevable
aussi de quelque chose il y a des gens
qui a une dette qui n'ont pas forcément
envie d'être redevable de l'héritage
familial que c'est trop lourd à porter
pour eux pour revenir à ces exemples que
vous citiez Johnny Hallyday des divorces
catastrophiques
Zuckerberg mais même dans les grandes
familles françaises les gens parce
qu'ils y voit les reflets de leur propre
turpitudes au sein de au sein de leur
famille et dans le cas de Johnny
Hallyday
ce qui était vraiment très intéressant
c'est que on voyait finalement
toute la France s'est levée pour
défendre Laura et David contre elle
avait chanté belle-mère contre contre le
les désirs de Johnny Hallyday qui était
des fins donc il ne pouvait plus
s'exprimer mais tout le monde pour
défendre les héritiers directs et donc
toujours par rapport à cette à cette loi
qui règne en France de la réserve
héréditaire il me fallait surtout pas
toucher à l'héritage des aînés qui leur
était dû au même titre que ses filles
adoptives et que sa belle-mère alors
Patrick Abran vous avez parlé
d'inconscient je voudrais vous poser
cette question d'actualité nous avons
assisté aux obsèques à travers les
médias
d'Élisabeth II et de la succession avec
Charles III
les médias français ont consacré à cette
occasion beaucoup d'encre beaucoup
d'images à votre avis
ça signifie quoi est-ce qu'on peut
relier ça avec le passé monarchique de
la France où est-ce que c'était à votre
avis une pure question de fric c'est à
dire ça marchait donc il fallait en
parler parce qu'il y a quelque chose
est-ce que vous l'héritage est ce que
joie à ce niveau là c'est à dire est-ce
qu'on peut relier des situations du
passé à une situation du présent et que
quelque chose se manifeste à cette
occasion il me semble que ça avoir avec
l'héritage que nous avons de la royauté
l'héritage tête tel que nous le vivons
c'est-à-dire le nom de celle de le Code
civil il est directement issu de la
Révolution c'est à dire plus exactement
la révolution ne l'avait pas fait et
c'est Napoléon qui l'a fait
il y a quand même toujours ce qui en
background c'est à dire que pour arriver
à cela il a fallu qu'on coupe la tête du
roi et ça a complètement changé
c'est-à-dire qu'effectivement les
enfants héritent tous au même niveau ce
qui permet de faire de joyeuses
querelles de famille puisque quand même
il y en a toujours un qui peut dire moi
j'y au droit plus que toi c'est sous
très souvent ce qui se passe et ce que
l'on voit il me semble ce qu'on a vu
c'était un un grand moment historique et
en même temps qui qui raconte une
histoire
mythologique c'est-à-dire que ce qu'on
était en train de nous dire vous êtes en
train de vivre l'histoire moi j'ai
entendu ça
par les commentateurs qui regardaient
alors entre deux entre deux séances
quand je vous vois quand même la
télévision et je regardais c'est je veux
dire c'est assez extraordinaire et
effectivement là il y a tout ce cet
héritage que nous avons peut-être perdu
et peut-être que nous rêvons nous
d'avoir comme ça des des défilés au
moment des obsèques mais il y a en même
temps ce qui est toujours présent je
pense c'est quand même le fait que c'est
extrêmement ancré entre en nous que ça
on doit transmettre à nos enfants il y a
quelque chose Johnny Hallyday c'était un
signe parmi d'autres mais ce qui je
pense a beaucoup frappé c'est que il
était il risquait de ne pas transmettre
à ses enfants et là il me semble qu'il y
a quelque chose qui est inscrit et que
l'on retrouve à chaque fois dans des
histoires de transmission Christian
Saint-Étienne
alors ça m'a frappé aussi ça m'a que
moyennement surpris mais ça m'a frappé
l'ampleur de l'écho de cet enterrement
en France mais donc on peut c'est une
possibilité d'explications le regret de
la monarchie en France
mais je pense qu'il y a une autre
explication qui d'ailleurs est
complémentaire de celle-là c'est que ça
comblait un vide parce que depuis
une trentaine d'années au minimum nous
vivons dans une période en France de
déconsidération totale du politique et
notamment des dirigeants et donc entre
des dirigeants le quinquennat de ce
point de vue a été une erreur colossale
dans l'histoire des institutions
françaises et avoir des gens qui tous
les cinq ans changent qui sont
d'ailleurs mal élus depuis plusieurs
présidents et qui sauf l'actuel qui a
été réélu mais dans le vide et qui
d'ailleurs a une popularité très limitée
donc on a des Français qui sont en
manque de représentation
globale historique philosophique
politique et donc ils se sont reportés
sur le Royaume-Uni en je pense que
l'intérêt que beaucoup de Français ont
porté à cet enterrement c'était
l'expression d'un désir que nous ayons
davantage de continuité à la tête de
l'État donc ça je c'est un des éléments
qu'on peut faire mais je voulais
rebondir sur une remarque de Boualem
sans salles tout à l'heure quand il a
dit que l'héritage était une énigme dans
à l'intérieur de cette énigme je pense
que si on s'interroge sur soi-même
d'une certaine façon l'héritage est
aussi à l'intérieur de l'individu une
disposition
une disposition au sens où on est tout
vert à recevoir un héritage qui sera
peut-être financier mais qui pour moi en
tout cas est fondamentalement culturel
et comportemental et où on n'est pas on
est totalement fermé à cette réception
moi je vois
je l'ai évoqué mais mes parents étaient
instituteurs dans un petit village du
sud de la France ils m'ont transmis
certainement dans la part inconsciente
de l'héritage des
envies de de
discipline d'excellence et autres mais
je me suis rendu compte assez vite que
j'avais une disposition à écouter mes
maîtres
par le paradoxe en tant qu'economiste
c'est que je ne respecte pas l'argent
pour moi c'est un instrument pur et je
ne respecte que le savoir mais chaque
fois que j'ai deux bons points de vue
identifié quelqu'un que pour moi je
considérais comme un maître je les
écoutais et ces gens que j'ai considérés
comme étant des maîtres qui m'ont donné
des conseils je les ai souvent suivis
alors c'est exactement vous avez évoqué
une variante tout à l'heure vous avez
dit mais il y a des gens qu'on connaît
Camus et qui sont pas devenus des grands
écrivains vous avez évoqué l'aspect du
talent mais je pense que cette
disposition à écouter à recevoir est un
élément clé et il y a des gens qui n'ont
pas cette disposition on leur ils ont
reçu alors vous disiez ils ont connu
Camus comme moi mais ils l'ont pas connu
comme vous l'avez connu c'est à dire que
vous aviez la disposition qui vous qui
vous a conduit à vous inspirer de lui et
il y en a d'autres qui ont connu qui
n'avait rien à [__]
j'ai souvent entendu et même dans mes
interviews des gens dire qui n'aimaient
pas l'argent et qui était très riche et
que finalement ils honoraires
mais alors qu'est-ce qu'il est poussé à
va faire de l'argent sans arrêt alors
c'est une
réponse à votre marque j'ai dit j'ai été
très précis j'ai dit que je ne
respectais pas l'argent j'ai pas dit que
je n'aimais pas l'argent et j'ai dit que
pour moi c'était un instrument pour moi
c'est un instrument de pouvoir donc je
n'ignore pas l'argent en tant
qu'instrument de pouvoir sinon pour moi
l'argent c'est ce qui permet d'investir
c'est ce qui permet de par exemple
réindustrialisé je n'ai pas de mépris de
l'argent je dis simplement la question
n'était pas moi non mais c'est une
question clé c'est-à-dire que je ne suis
pas en train de dire que l'argent n'a
pas d'importance en tant qu'instrument
il a de l'importance mais dans ma
hiérarchie personnelle je respecte un
savant et je peux respecter un chef
d'entreprise qui a créé oui j'ai bien
compris en revanche un héritier qui a
simplement de l'argent pour moi ce n'est
rien mais alors justement juste un mot
Patrick Abran peut-être un mot
analytique qu'est-ce qui quelqu'un à
avoir de plus en plus d'argent parce que
ça motive sinon les gens ne seraient pas
à courir après les fortunes mais on n'a
pas le temps de faire toute la thèse
freudienne juste un mot
ne tient pas compte d'une chose elle
tient pas compte de la monnaie sauf que
j'ai écrit alors on crée un petit livre
qui s'appelle petite psychanalyse de
l'argent ou effectivement considérer
l'argent comme un outil c'est-à-dire de
la monnaie et à partir de ce moment-là
on comprend que en fonction de la façon
dont on vit le monde soit on a envie
d'avoir tout le pouvoir possible
imaginer qu'on peut tout posséder à ce
moment-là on a le plus d'argent possible
soit on peut se contenter d'avoir ce qui
nous est dans une correspondance entre
Freud et Kate
ils étaient d'accord là-dessus considéré
que l'argent c'était de la merde
pardonnez-moi cette vulgarité dans le
terme mais il y a là quelque chose qui
dirait que c'est de la merde c'est
considéré qu'effectivement l'argent est
une chose et à ce moment-là c'est le
stade anal freudien on oublie que il y a
un pas de plus à faire il me semble
c'est que l'argent c'est pas une chose
l'argent c'est un moyen d'échange
strictement l'argent ça n'existe pas
c'est la monnaie qui est un mot clair
oui courir après l'argent comme vous le
dites et n'être pas disposé à le
transmettre à ses enfants ça c'est très
anglo-saxon ce sont tous ces
milliardaires américains qui ne veulent
rien léguer mais rien à leurs enfants
c'est aussi une réponse j'ai trouvé chez
certains patrons français
rebondir
on va revenir là-dessus ce que je
voulais simplement dire c'est qu'il faut
par rapport à ce que la question que
vous posez c'est distinguer l'argent
pour soi et l'argent comme instrument et
c'est pas du tout la même chose
accumuler de l'argent c'est donc le
pour bâtir quelque chose ce sont deux
notions très différentes n’empêche que
certains jouissent de l'argent oui
[Musique]
alors Claire Fournier je vais pas vous
accabler encore pour une première fois
mais là c'est au cœur de votre livre
alors penchons-nous sur les correctifs
qui permettent si possible de rendre
l'héritage plus vertueux qu'est-ce que
vous pensez justement de ces
milliardaires
américains qui ont qui laissent en
héritage peu d'argent à leurs enfants
mais qu'il crée des fondations et dont
on est dans ton lit dans les magazines
qui restent les plus grosses fortunes
alors déjà pas une hypocrisie là-dedans
c'est merveilleux ce que disait Carnegie
vous allez vous allez ruiner vos enfants
si vous leur léguer trop ça me fait
penser un milliardaire plus proche de
nous Warren Buffett qui dit il faut
laisser suffisamment d'argent à vos à
vos enfants pour qu'ils puissent en
faire quelque chose mais pas assez pour
qu'il n'en fasse intervenir en
conclusion de Warren Buffett c'est très
anglo-saxon de dire j'ai fait
je le dois à la société donc je dois
redonner cet argent à la société et pas
à mes enfants on est là complètement à
l'opposé de ce qui fait l'héritage chez
nous en France où il faut absolument
léguer à ses enfants directs parce que
jusqu'au 18e siècle grosso modo
l'héritage c'était quoi c'était des
terres et même encore il y a pas si
longtemps c'était souvent des terrains
donc il fallait pas qu'il soit divisés
etc bon aux États-Unis c'est vraiment
l'idée d'ailleurs qui est liée à la
culture anglicane à la religion
anglicane qu'il faut reverser à la
société donc vous avez aujourd'hui c'est
c'est ces dirigeants notamment qui ont
fait ce giving plage vous savez cette ce
serment de données qui donne jusqu'à 99%
de leur fortune c'est le fameux Warren
Buffett et c'est également Bill et
Melinda Gates qui le font donc ce sont
eux il faut aussi replacer ça dans le
contexte américain dans la mesure où
comme l'état n'est pas un État
providence ne finance pas ni les
hôpitaux ni la culture ni les écoles
il y a la place pour de riches mécène
pour intervenir
c'est pas une colle mais on sait qu'en
France 60 personnes 60% pardon des
personnes qui
héritent
c'est pas acquis d'héritage autrement
dit et
si vous voulez avoir un patrimoine il
vaut mieux être du côté des héritiers
est-ce que c'est mieux aux États-Unis
est-ce que vous pensez est-ce que le
pourcentage
sous les ponts bien évidemment je vous
parle du pourcentage au niveau de la
société est-ce que la société américaine
est plus égalitaire que la société
donc finalement ces Américains
milliardaires c'est de la cerise sur le
gâteau ils viennent compenser un état
qui n'est pas un État providence comme
comme en Europe comme comme en France
mais je effectivement vous vous
soulignez ce chiffre de 60% ça c'est le
chiffre qui m'a poussé à écrire ce livre
je sais qu'on va reparler d'inégalités
mais il est vraiment très frappant
la part de l'héritage dans le patrimoine
aujourd'hui elle est de 60% en effet
dans les années 70 elle était de
en effet donc c'est pour ça qu'il y a de
plus en plus d'inégalités liées à
l'héritage je sais que je m'éloigne un
peu de votre question sur les études
a été tienne vous qui êtes un économiste
libéral vous êtes favorable à ce qu'on
réduise ce
décalage que entre les années 60 et
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit qu'on passe de
30% à 60% de privilégier c'est-à-dire
ceux qui ont un patrimoine ça vient de
l'héritage alors est-ce qu'il faut pas
sans instaurer chacun a ses idées
politiques mais disons sans faire du
socialisme
oppressif est-ce qu'il y a pas là
quelque chose à corriger en termes
d'inégalité alors d'abord il faut
rappeler que les la taxation l'héritage
en France au delà d'un certain
patrimoine et très élevé contrairement
aux États-Unis ou c'est relativement
faible donc il y a déjà une taxation
très importante il faut également
rappeler que sur les fruits les du
patrimoine c'est-à-dire sur les revenus
nous sommes un des pays qui taxe le plus
au monde c'est-à-dire que les
prélèvements
que vous interroge alors les inégalités
dont on parle ici elle concerne une
fraction de la population et ce qui
m'intéresse moi c'est ce qu'ils en font
c'est à dire que si ce patrimoine
devient un patrimoine de jouissance où
on achète des bateaux de luxe ou des
voitures non non mais et si par ailleurs
dans une approche
peut-être
plus
calvince qui est à côté de vous vous
dira que dans le monde la part
d'altruisme et d'égoïsme est équivalent
non non mais c'est pas ça que je dis je
dis si la l'héritage que vous recevez
vous l'utilisez pour développer
l'activité économique qui va créer des
emplois pour les autres ça ça n'a pas la
même signification
donc l'héritage en soi
à partir du moment où il est déjà très
fiscalisé si on l'utilise pour
développer des activités économiques
c'est c'est une bonne chose alors je
complète ce chiffre non mais je complète
ce chiffre parce que il faisait un
chiffre très peu connu qui est que
l'essentiel de cet héritage attention
c'est très très important c'est de
l'héritage productif c'est à dire que
l'essentiel grand héritage ce sont des
héritages d'action d'entreprise si ce
qui héritent de ces actions font
fructifier les entreprises ça n'a pas du
tout la même signification il faut pas
oublier non plus que cette dans la
l'héritage actuel il y a énormément
d'immobilier aussi donc là on ne parle
pas de productif
quand vous arrivez au plus gros héritage
en France plus de 60% des héritages
c'est du patrimoine industriel
on bientôt à la fin peut-être une
question pour les deux écrivains et
psychanalyste à votre avis
vous êtes écrivain Patrick abra des
psychanalyste est-ce que vous pensez que
quand on a en soi cette notion
d'héritage est-ce que ça favorise le
talent ça favorise le risque ou
inversement ça vous met dans une
position de vivre sur des acquis
on a très peu de temps
je dirais que l'héritage quel que soit
la situation quel que soit le moment
renvoie toujours à une histoire d'idéale
c'est-à-dire quand on hérite on est
nécessairement qu'on le veuille ou non
qu'on le sache ou non confronter à
toutes les générations qui nous ont
précédés et donc ça pose des questions
de cette idéal que plus ou moins présent
plus ou moins visible et qui est là
après peut-être qu'on peut en faire
effectivement
autre chose que ce qu'on fait nos
ancêtres mais la question est là nous
sommes confrontés à quelque chose qui
nous dépasse quand on hérite je vais
vous présenter une bibliographie alors
Patrick Abran vous avez publié
hérité une histoire de famille
si vous l'avez fait pour vos enfants
d'abord je ne sais pas s'ils l'ont lu
mais je l'ai fait parce que j'ai été
hérité j'ai été héritier pas forcément
d'une grande fortune et je pense que je
vais sans doute léguer à un moment et
puis ça fait partie des questions
pas forcément que les psychanalystes
entendent toujours sur leur dire mais ça
fait quand même partie des questions qui
traversent à un moment ou un autre
l'histoire de tout un chacun qui
l'hérite d'une fortune ou de rien du
tout merci alors Claire Fournier
repenser
héritage on sait tout
sur les inégalités causées par les
ritage
sincèrement vous avez le livret très
bien fait très documenté mais est-ce
qu'il y a un côté
j'allais dire c'est affreux ce que
j'avais dire vengeance familiale quelque
chose non non évidemment un sujet qui
m'intéresse pour des raisons
personnelles mais je l'ai écrit alors
non pas pour mes enfants mais pour les
politiques parce que c'est un sujet qui
est monté très fort pendant la campagne
présidentielle et malheureusement
maintenant que on a un président réélu
on voit bien que ce sujet était
totalement écarté alors qu'il y a
beaucoup de choses à faire parce qu'il y
a aussi une chose dont on n'a pas parlé
c'est que aujourd'hui la question de
votre émission c'est à qui profite
l'héritage il profite énormément aux
personnes âgées et évidemment par
rapport aux jeunes parce qu'aujourd'hui
on hérite à 50 ans et que très bientôt
on arrêtera à 60 ans donc si vous voulez
ça devient une rente pour retraités
mais c'est un facteur et vous avez bien
fait de souligner alors Christian
Saint-Étienne le libéralisme stratège
contre le chaos du monde vous restez
toujours un économiste libérale où vous
pensez qu'aujourd'hui avec les
difficultés que nous connaissons et qui
sont qui se multiplient il y a quelque
chose à d'autres à tenter alors ceux qui
les rendent le livre verront que mon
libéralisme qui s'appelle libéralisme
stratège c'est un libéralisme avec un
état stratège qui guide des grands
investissements pour permettre à la
société de se développer mais je voulais
faire une remarque puisque vous avez
évoquez le mot libéral
il y a une statistique peu de temps
vraiment il y a une statistique je
voudrais simplement vous donner
la Loterie Nationale a étudié les gens
le comportement des gens qui reçoivent
une énorme somme d'argent
dans 80% des cas ça se passe très mal
quand ils ont pas le patrimoine
intellectuel culturelle pour gérer cette
somme mais 80% des héritages de
d'entreprises familiales se passent bien
donc l'héritage il faut bien distinguer
la somme d'argent et des étages
parmi vos nombres livres on a choisi
Abraham la 5e alliance pourquoi Abraham
on avait en deux mots puisqu'on a très
peu de temps c'est quoi l'héritage
d'Abraham quand on est un grand écrivain
algérien Abraham se serait un idéal en
ce moment on voit bien que le monde est
divisé
par les religions évidemment les
considérations
politiques stratégiques etc et militaire
mais le fond de la le fond de la
question c'est les religieuse
se retrouver Abraham s'est retrouvé
l'unité
des trois religions du Livre le judaïsme
le christianisme et l'islam gardons ça
si vous voulez bien
cette science-fiction aujourd'hui on en
a besoin alors il me reste à vous
remercier merci d'avoir participé à
cette émission merci à la brillante
équipe d'aide CP et je vous soumets
avant de partir cette citation de Warren
Buffett qui n'est pas inédite puisque
Claire Fournier l'a déjà dévoilé une
personne très riche doit laisser
suffisamment à ses enfants pour qu'il
fasse ce qu'ils veulent mais pas assez
pour qu'il ne fasse rien
[Musique]